[Music]
queen elizabeth ii britain's longest
reigning monarch passed away today
in scotland at the age of 96 according
to buckingham palace she died peacefully
this afternoon after her health
reportedly took a turn for the worst and
as britain and the world mourns the loss
of this iconic and revered leader she
was loved by her country and by millions
of people all across the world and with
queen elizabeth's passing charles will
now become and is now the king now
charles called his mother's death quote
a moment of the greatest sadness for me
and all members of my family adding
quote i know her loss will be deeply
felt throughout the country and the
realms and the commonwealth and by
countless people all around the world
here now is the host of uncensored piers
morgan and fox and friends co-host
ainsley earhart uh aisli you piers and
martha did the
coverage for the platinum jubilee for
the channel
and what really amazed me today she took
the throne at the age of 25.
she is died now at 96 and from the very
first day she became queen they were
planning for this day and this now
there's a whole series of events that'll
happen tell us about it
yeah so it's a 10-day process and
they've been planning this they planned
this when you know every single king or
queen has ever existed here's what will
happen next day one obviously everyone
is notified prime minister was notified
first and then the new king is
officially named immediately when she
dies all flags are flown at half staff
and then king charles is supposed to
address the nation on tv whether that
will happen tonight probably not because
it's late in the uk probably tomorrow
then on day three and four
king charles will set off on his first
uk tour as king
and then london will prepare for her
funeral with rehearsals day five the
procession from buckyham palace to the
houses of parliament and then she will
lie in state for three days and the
public will be able to pay respects and
to go and visit day six through nine
king charles will visit the welsh
parliament and there will be a service
at a cathedral and then day ten is the
funeral and if you look at the dates
that would be next saturday so next
weekend probably the funeral it'll be a
day of mourning a two-minute moment of
silence over all of britain the funeral
at westminster abbey and then the
committal service at the saint george's
chapel uh at windsor castle which is
about an hour outside of london and then
buried
king george the fourth memorial chapel
sean
pierce i don't know if you remember this
conversation we had but we had a really
lengthy conversation and it's
it's very memorable to me because i
asked you you have this connection to
the royal family very unique a knowledge
second to none
and with incredible passion you outlined
and laid out to me why it was so
important to you the royal family and so
important to the people of britain
convey that today and and specifically
your relationship with them
you know sean this is honestly one of
the saddest days of my life and i'll
tell you why it's because in america you
have presidents they're kind of like
your royal family in a way each time
they come along but they're only ever
there for a maximum of eight years and
then they move on
this queen has been on the throne of
this country for 70 years
so i'm 57 years old she's been the only
monarch i've ever had in this country
and she was already reigning for 13
years before i was born
she has straddled so much change
in our society here in our country she's
steered us through good times and bad
she's been through pandemics and
terrorism attacks and natural disasters
um you know the tragedies we should
befall on the country or other countries
and whether she's been helping us to
celebrate or whether she's been
consoling us she's been this constant
rock of support and she represents sean
in my opinion the very best of british
values stoicism resilience
duty
humility
strength of character
never plays the victim
always looking forward always putting
the country before herself
these kind of leaders are incredibly
unusual you know i would imagine if she
ever ran for public office which she
obviously never did she would have won
by a massive landslide and being the
greatest prime minister
we we ever had because she had all the
qualities you want from a leader and of
course she met 13 american presidents
she met 15 british prime ministers
another 100 world leaders so she was
gathering all the time this
extraordinary amount of knowledge and
wisdom about leadership from leaders and
about the world and it made her one of
the wisest people i've certainly ever
met i met her on a number of occasions
had the great privilege of it and she
was a remarkably intelligent and feisty
and
strong woman and you know when i heard
today somebody rang me uh very close to
the royal family and rumors have been
swirling all day about what may be going
on we knew it was serious all the royal
family were going up to balmoral
rumors were circulating and someone
called me and said
piers i'm really sorry but the queen has
passed and it was like i was
hit in the back honestly it was like a
jolt to me and i told my family
immediately and they were all completely
horrified and shocked and and upset
and it's hard to describe to people who
aren't british why it means so much to
us
but it really does it's touched all of
us and i've shed a tear or two today and
i'm sure i will over the next few days
because she was really this country's
grandmother
well what a powerful statement you made
uh piers and by the way
uh my deepest condolences to you and to
all the people of great britain i
remember
uh both you and ainsley and martha in
the platinum jubilee coverage uh ainsley
i remember specifically you had many
anecdotal stories about her life her
loves her passions remind people some of
that
yeah i you know i fell in love with her
too and pierce my art our sympathies to
you and to all the people of great
britain and we loved her too you know
all of the the women over here in
america we all are little girls deep
down inside and we fantasized about
being princesses when we were little and
um we we just loved her and we're
hopeless romantics at heart and we love
just to follow the royal family and
visit london and it's just such a
special place and it was a pleasure to
work with you pierce and i know how much
you love her and some of the stories
that i learned when i was doing my
research for the platinum jubilee are
really she had a sense of humor her
grandfather everyone was scared of him
king george and she would visit him and
he had a pet parrot named susie and
actually charlotte susie was her dog
that she took on her honeymoon uh the
pet parrot was charlotte and charlotte
was walking back and forth on the dining
room table and she would feed the parrot
sugar cubes and the grandfather would
let the parrot do that he also had a
beard and she would lead him around his
house
by the beard and the archbishop of
canterbury witnessed this and was taken
aback and said basically this child is
the only one that would be able to do
that and lead him around his house like
he was a horse and they would play
together
she loved her dogs her corgis she had 30
of them over the course of her of her
reign and she even took one on her
honeymoon as i said she loved her
husband she loved prince philip and she
met him at 13 years old he was basically
assigned to babysit her at the naval
institution in in dartmouth and uh she
fell in love with him at 13 and then
they were married they were engaged
later in life and they announced the
engagement when she was 21 and they were
married
she you know he said he said the secret
of of a wedding
when asked is tolerance because we know
he you know he he had his mischievous
side and she said after he died that
mischievous inquiring twinkle was as
bright at the end as it was when i first
set eyes on him her father uh when he
died she became queen unbeknownst to her
in the middle of the night she woke up
and philip had to tell her and he said
it was the hardest conversation i've
ever had with her and her lady in
waiting was watching them pace back and
forth and when the queen came inside she
realized she hugged her and then she
realized i'm hugging the queen and she
knelt down and she cursed me but can i
end with this uh when her father died
sean she said we are all just visitors
this time this place we are just passing
through our purpose here is to learn to
grow to love and then we return home
last question piers how will great
britain respond to king charles
you know it's a big challenge because
there's no one like the queen and she's
irreplaceable really and we've never
known any different the only good thing
he has going from i think well you've
got many good qualities but the good
thing is going from he's been waiting
for this moment for his entire life it's
been the longest apprenticeship ever and
of course he was learning at the seat of
the greatest monarch there's ever been
so i actually think charles will be a
very good king albe he'll face a lot of
challenges about how to modernize the
monarchy and move it forward and to keep
it going now that we've lost this
enormous light you know i remember being
in the summer with you ainsley and with
martha
right in the center of things outside
the palace and when the queen walked out
what i'm grateful for is that we had
that moment as a country and the world
to show her what she meant for us and
there was such euphoria down the mall
that day and i think
we all felt this excitement it was
unbelievably thrilling to be able to say
to her thank you mom for this incredible
reign and the other solace we have is
that she's now reunited with prince
philip and they're the only two good
things that have come on what is the one
of the saddest days in the history of
this country i wish charles all the very
best he'll become charles iii uh and i
thank all my american friends who've
been i've got to say
a number of people have contacted me
just to check that i'm okay and and to
send their condolences it's really
touching she moved the entire world and
i know americans loved her and share our
loss and we are a nation in deep
mourning tonight
what would a line just passing through
all of us just passing through piers
morgan uh our deepest condolences uh to
you and our friends in great britain uh
thank you ainsley earhart thank you as
well hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else